we are learning more almost daily about
the reach of Russian interference in
American politics and it goes well
beyond the 2016 election even though on
this show a lot of our focus has been
around that you might know that Donald
Trump's FCC almost immediately rolled
back the Obama era net neutrality
regulations that were put in place
during President Obama's presidency and
the entire process was just an utterly
embarrassing fiasco we had first of all
Ajit PI a former Verizon lawyer brought
in as FCC Chairman the FCC's contact
form
supposedly spontaneously shut down
during the comment period we later found
out that a ton of fake astroturf
comments were submitted by people
claiming to be against net neutrality
even though in reality almost no one is
against net neutrality and the latest is
that we've now learned that Russia
interfered in the net neutrality process
as admitted by Donald Trump's FCC
Chairman Ajit PI again a former Verizon
lawyer the New York Times
filed a lawsuit to get access to records
around the public comments that were
made and in the course of this lawsuit
Ajit PI admitted that it is a quote fact
that there was Russian interference in
the public comments related to the net
neutrality repeal and as I've told you
before of the real comments almost 100
percent wanted to keep Obama's net
neutrality regulations we now know
thanks to this lawsuit that 9.5 million
people's identities were stolen for use
in fake comments 8 million comments were
filed from domains associated with fake
mail generator comm and about 500,000
comments were from Russian email
addresses the argument being made and
the argument which needs to be
considered is whether a GTI tried to
conceal Russian interference here
because it benefits his political
position on the issue now they're trying
to preempt this by saying no some of the
Russian comments were Pro net neutrality
but what everybody making that argument
doesn't
seem to understand is that if a hundred
percent of the Russian comments were
against net neutrality or only ninety
percent were against net neutrality or
only 80 percent of Russian comments were
against net neutrality it's not actually
about that specifically it's that this
is part of the decades old very
well-established Russian geopolitical
agenda which includes sowing discord in
the United States it includes
particularly sowing discord in ways that
will destabilize the democratic
institutions that are important to the
United States and the Internet's a huge
part of that the Internet's a huge part
of many types of democracy a free and
open press today depends on the internet
digital democracy depends on the
Internet so by interfering the Russian
goal isn't necessarily to flip the
results of the net neutrality repeal
vote it's to shake up these key
institutions that make the United States
what it is
so what a GTI should be criticized for
depends on what the truth of the
situation is and that's what we're
trying to figure out number one a GTI
possibly was involved in concealing the
reality around the entire a failure of
the comment system and couching it as
like a spontaneous denial of service
thing that happened because of demand it
appears that that's not true it appears
he knew pretty early on what was going
on here number two a GTI may have
attempted to conceal known Russian
influence in the net neutrality repeal
campaign which was ultimately successful
for a GTI and Trump's FCC and number
three did a GTI obstruct an
investigation into this for as long as
possible he stood aside and put out
bogus statements as it was very clear
that the comments were number one being
manipulated that were coming in and
number two the comment system itself was
under attack he's disgusting he should
be fired but instead in this
administration this is the type of thing
that gets people rewarded this is the
type of thing that gets people praised
from
Trump not likely that he would actually
be fired in this case and this is part
of this trifecta or it's even really
more than three Net Neutrality ranked
choice voting which we talked about
earlier this week and last week in
interviews a campaign finance reform
climate change right those four issues
are sort of the meta issues that as
progressives were working on right now
and Donald Trump in the same way that
his Supreme Court picks if we consider
the Supreme Court sort of item five on
that meta list of issues Donald Trump's
Supreme Court picks will have far sort
of cascading far-ranging impact on the
United States if we don't fix the net
neutrality situation and like really
really soon that is also going to have
an extraordinarily destructive impact on
the United States as well send me your
thoughts send me your thoughts about
Russian interference in the FCC repeal
of net neutrality send me your thoughts
more generally about what we need to do
about net neutrality we have a great
program for you today I will be taking
calls after the break we have an
extraordinary classic interview I will
also finally be addressing the phrase no
homo later on in today's show a bunch of
people wrote in about this including
Eric who wants to know whether no homo
is de facto a homophobic slur I will
deal with that later in the show we have
a fantastic bonus show planned for you
and you can reach me on twitter at de
Pakman make sure while you're at it also
follow the show on twitter at david
pakman show it's Friday
glad you're with us plenty more coming
up one of today's sponsors is Skillshare
which is an incredible online learning
community offering over 10,000
high-quality online courses on a huge
variety of topics first 500 who click
the link under this video will get two
entire months of totally free access to
every single class that Skillshare
offers you'll have free access to
courses on music art photography
business computer programming cooking
meditation and everything in between I
think you'll have no problem finding
courses that are perfect for you just
took
really great class on graphic design
which I know nothing about but I'm
trying to learn our show is giving you
two entire months of totally free access
to every course Skillshare offers risk
free if you click the link under this
video you'll have two months to take
classes on anything you're passionate
about classes taught by real people who
share that passion and after that you
can keep getting access to the entire
site for less than ten bucks a month
just click the link under this video to
redeem your to three months of
Skillshare but hurry it's only available
to the first 500 who sign up